rob is spoken about some of the issues
that face Nexus and you wouldn't be here
if you didn't believe in its mission but
I hope you will say to other people what
what I feel about it which is that this
is the only conference or gathering I
ever go to we're on the same platform
you can find an admiral and an opera
singer that's going to happen later
today it's truly amazing the range of
human ingenuity and talent that gets
brought together at Nexus that's the
first wonderful and unique thing about
this organization but the other thing is
you the second thing that makes Nexus
unique has always been the audience
because this is not a gathering of
specialists or little elite Conclave
it's always been a gathering for the
citizens of a great city and it's the
only conference of its kind that I know
that reaches out in this way to the
citizens of a great city so I just you
know speaking personally on behalf of
Susanna my wife is also here I I do hope
that the Netherlands finds a way to keep
this wonderful and quite unique
experiment going in the future okay
let's do some work together I'm sitting
I'm standing on the the set of a vogner
production so we better begin with
vogner the ring could be interpreted as
a mythic genealogy of human emotion it
describes the battle between the
impulses of love and the drive for power
played out inside our own Souls way back
to our archaic beginnings our fate
vogner tells us is tragic we should
choose love but we always choose power
and in the drive for domination we use
technology Tecna
to control nature and other human beings
and reason driven on by acquisitive lust
gives us godlike powers
but in gaining the ring we doom
ourselves to got Adama wrong we
abandoned the gods and they abandoned us
and in the Twilight we are left
struggling often in vain to use these
godlike powers
with wisdom and foresight and the wise
use of power of ogner tells us can only
come when we love our fellow creatures
and respect the only planet we know as
our common home now this summary might
not satisfy the true vogner ian's in the
audience and it mote work as a summary
of one of Western arts most profound and
troubling masterpieces but it does tease
out a theme that I want to concentrate
on for the rest of this lecture vogner
is attention to man's alienating and
alienated relation to nature and the
price we pay when domination the drive
for the ring causes us to lose our love
of the natural world and see it only as
a resource to be plundered and this
establishes the theme of my lecture
which is the impact of the environmental
crisis on our understanding of history
in the last twenty years or so we all
seem to have realized that mankind has
entered a new epoch the Anthropocene in
which the chief forces shaping nature
are the work of our own species
now some date the dawn of the
Anthropocene - the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution and some trace it
back to 1945 and Hiroshima and Nagasaki
but whatever the dating we know we're
living in a new epoch in which human
beings must assume responsibility for
natural phenomenon
the weather sea-levels air quality soil
fertility that we once attributed to God
or to fake in this lecture I want to
think through just a few of the
political consequence of what it means
to live in the Anthropocene this new age
in which for the first time human beings
like us hold the future of our whole
species in our hands vogner's
Gotterdammerung reminds us that while
the concept of the Anthropocene is new
the general idea that man's godlike
powers now endanger our very survival is
a very well-established theme way back
in the 19th century this pessimism even
then expressed itself in warnings of
environmental nemesis we should recall
that when Gotterdammerung finally occurs
in the final act of the Ring the Rhine
Rises its banks and floods the world
nature takes its revenge on human
presumption and folly from its first
performance Wagner's audience has been
has understood the Gotterdammerung as a
fable about ecological destruction and
capitalist greed and this theme has
surfaced in interpretations of the ring
ever since this emerging narrative of
catastrophe is putting enormous pressure
on all our political beliefs now there's
still some conservative parties some US
Republicans for example who deny the
basic facts but we we can be pretty sure
I think that any politics that denies
the facts doesn't have much of a future
and then their populace on the right
salvini or bond builders take your pick
who change the subject who tell you the
thing to fear is not climate change but
immigrants and foreigners but politics
that changes the subject doesn't have
much of a future either it's only the
greens surging in Western Europe
especially here in the Netherlands that
have identified climate change as a sin
a political issue of our time but it's
important to notice that they still
don't command support from more than a
quarter of the electorate many of whom I
hope and suppose maybe in the room this
morning I think the reason that green
support has stole dat about 25 percent
of the electorate is that the green
agenda asks for more change than most
electors are as yet ready to make the
cut the times may be revolutionary but
people are not yet ready for a
revolutionary politics for no political
movement does climate change pose a more
difficult challenge than liberalism the
political force that I've been
associated in my lifetime by liberalism
by the way I mean a centrist gradualist
politics of all stripes it comes
liberalism can come in small C
conservative social democratic forms it
can come in some green forms so when I
talk about liberalism I don't get hung
up on party political labels liberal
convictions seem out of step with a
fashionable apocalyptic mood that warns
us that we're all headed for
Gotterdammerung our institutions are in
crisis elites have failed capitalism has
failed own so vital and so vital and so
vital so climate puts the historical
story of progress on trial and it puts
liberal politics in the dog and in the
face of the great fear of climate
catastrophe liberal politics may be
swept aside climate change if
sufficiently frightening could cause us
to vote ourselves into an authoritarian
state so climate emergency will test the
viability of liberal democratic
societies more than populism ever will
but that's not really the core challenge
the core challenge runs deeper there's a
deeper crisis in the liberal confidence
in the very stories we tell about our
past in this story we tell the story
that it was tech
a technology that lifted the burden of
labour off the backs of men and women it
was medical science that enabled women
to face childbirth without terror it was
science that gave us the prospect that
everyone could be born grow up and live
a normal life that freed millions and
then billions from starvation and hunger
this is the inves is the Enlightenment
story the wonderful story that we
inherit from bacon from Newton from Adam
Smith onwards the empowering
relationship between knowledge and
freedom and this is what liberated
mankind from servitude hunger disease
and premature death and frankly it's the
only good story left it's the one that
made us feel that all the senseless
brutality of capitalist modernity served
a higher purpose even if we could not
see it or even enjoy it ourselves I want
to make the point that we've made more
progress in understanding the science of
climate within the last 80 years than in
the entire history of humanity and
that's something we have a widely
diffused and generalized awareness
spreading way beyond narrow scientific
circles of something called an echo
sphere of interactions and correlations
between environmental phenomenon on sea
land and air that we never suspected
before we've made striking progress in
aligning market incentives and
regulation so that for the first time
renewable energy now competes with
fossil fuels and nuclear but despite
this intellectual and technical
revolution it's common these days to
read articles in which our species is
described as a virus as an infestation
or even as the chief serial killer on
the planet thanks to these metaphors we
worry aloud whether we actually deserve
to survive at all instead of feeling
empowered but what by what we have come
to know the more we know the worse we
feel
so we've met the enemy as the great
American cartoonist Pogo used to say and
he is us or she is us so what do we do
about us being human demands of all of
us a dual act of recognition taking
responsibility for what is worst in our
history as a species while keeping faith
with our cunning our resilience are
staggering resourcefulness we should
admit that the stories in which we
attempt to give shape to time and
Gotterdammerung is merely one of them
our fables at once deceiving and self
deceiving but the past itself the
physical remains the old stones the
pictures gleaming from the walls the
howl Birds taking the light in
Rembrandt's Night Watch the light on the
Pearl Earring the bent lentils over
which we step the immense secretion of
the human presence its tenacity
ingenuity brilliance and vision this is
inspiring because it reminds us once
again what human beings fortified by
faith in themselves and in purpose is
larger than themselves can accomplish
this is the faith we need to save our
planet
thank you
[Applause]